ceasefire means there is no military
solution only a diplomatic and cultural
solution AOC followed up at that very
same rally and she seems to think there
is no military solution which is why she
wants a ceasefire although I suspect if
Israel was losing right now she would
not be calling for a ceasefire I don't
think it takes a rocket science a rocket
scientist to figure that out take a look
ceasefire means there is no military
solution only a diplomatic and cultural
solution a relational solution a
Reckoning with ourselves and our history
that is what SE fire now means I mean
it's just pure Dil I'm sorry I have no
other way to describe it there's no
military solution well first off we know
that there is the destruction of Hamas
the return of the hostages and and
borders that are clean that if they're
you know ransacked over uh obviously
you're going to do what you got to do
but she thinks there's a diplomatic and
cultural solution uh mayor as someone
that lives in Israel can you talk about
not only how no Israelis live in Gaza
and haven't lived in Gaza since 2005 but
I haven't heard one Israeli since well
maybe in the last three weeks been like
we got to send some Israelis there but
nobody wants anything to do with the
place but there should be a diplomatic
and cultural answer well I think this is
just a very clear example of when
somebody from the West thinks that they
understand something to to no ends even
though they have no real skin in the
game I mean it's very very clear
diplomacy is simple it's the
conversation that leads leads to peace
right you have to have two people on the
table who are interested in getting to a
peaceful solution Kamas are clear
they're not interested in that and
they're also clear they're not
interested in conversation if you look
at the hostage situation you'll see they
have no interest in talking to us so
somebody coming and spouting idiocy
basically saying something along the
lines of oh let's just have a
conversation about it is obviously so
unaware of the realities of the
situation and to claim that there's no
military solution there is a very simple
military solution
the eradication ofas exactly as the IDF
is doing right now and the fact that you
stand up there and say such things to an
audience is again shocking but we know
that Amy there was a military solution
to the Nazis wasn't
there yeah this is what moral confusion
looks like remember her rant in Congress
um AOC is like you know I I think that
it it runs very deep it's it's this idea
that perhaps on the very far left when
face with evil you know there's this
temptation to externalize it and this
this happens across the board no actors
are actually involved here there are no
aggressors there's no behavior on
hamas's part that's accountable for this
um and therefore to do that all of a
sudden war and conflict just come upon
Humanity like some some force that we
can't control it's like no no no no no
if you want peace if you want peace you
need to eliminate those who don't share
your value for peace who don't desire
peace it's wonderful to say the the
solution to war is peace but that is a
meaningless expression when you have
actors and regimes involved committed to
the destruction of one per people and
acted out so yeah we want peace how do
you get peace you eliminate and fight
those people who are violently opposed
to it and this just displays such a you
know a moral confusion when look when
when faced with evil and a historical
ignorance of the five times Israel has
offered Palestinian statehood and met
with further violence and aggression and
maybe even the 17 to 20 oh nearly 20
years of Israel leaving Gaza as an
experiment and look what happens so you
know I just if she if she really thought
it through or you know the real case to
be made is if you want to fight for a
pre free Palestinian State you need to
eliminate those who stand in the way of
it which is clearly Hamas they they
don't talk about you know creating a
two-state solution and talk about
diplomacy they talk about committing
genocide against Jews worldwide and
eliminating the state of Israel and now
we're seeing it unapologetically on the
streets proas rallies not pro two State
Solutions and then she has Thea to talk
about ceasefires and peace and without
that recognition it's hard to believe
it's not willful but that's what we're
seeing